[Música]
el miedo es una de las emociones más
poderosas
qué determina las decisiones que tomamos
en cada segundo de nuestras vidas
está ubicada en la amígdala que es una
parte del cerebro que está conectada con
el sistema nervioso
la amígdala está atenta a cualquier
peligro
cuando detecta a uno más de información
este sistema nervioso entonces la
respiración se dispara los músculos se
contraen la percepción del tiempo cambia
todo se vuelve más lento
en cuestión de microsegundos es capaz de
generar una reacción involuntaria pero
que a la vez ha permitido la
sobrevivencia en nuestra especie
frente al miedo hay dos reacciones
avanzamos y nos defendemos
fuimos
yo por ejemplo le tengo muchísimo miedo
a las serpientes a las multitudes como
ustedes pero también le tengo muchísimo
miedo y siempre he tenido mucho miedo
algo que me ha acompañado por los 28
años de mi vida salir del closet con mi
mamá
y es que para las personas que no han
salido del closet con sus mamás les
explico más o menos cómo funciona esta
sensación
es como cuando están subiendo a la
montaña rusa y están así en el pico y el
vagón está a punto de girar hacia abajo
entonces comienzan a sentir vértigo
náuseas mareos le sudan las manos la
sensación de que todo terminará
eso sumado a algo que nos acompaña a
todos los hijos
voy a fallarle a mi mamá
finalmente lo hice y lo hice el día que
ella llegó un día a mi casa y me dijo
la verdad es que no sé quién eres no te
conozco siento que vivo con un inquilino
en ese momento tomé la decisión y me
lancé
mama
soy gay
el poder de la negación es tan grande
que tuve que salir del closet dos veces
mi mamá se olvidó de mi revelación
entonces al día siguiente comenzó a
preguntarme por chicas futuras novia así
que cuando me iba a casar
yo le entendí a mí me costó 28 años
aceptarme y no podía pedirle a ella que
me acepte de un momento a otro
hasta que llegó el día
yo recuerdo esa noche claramente yo
llegué a mi casa llorando destrozado con
el corazón roto
bueno estarás contenta ya me rompieron
pues
esa noche dormía en su cama y al día
siguiente ella me llevó a almorzar
cuando terminamos de almorzar mi mamá me
dijo gabriel te voy a dar un consejo
piensas en todos sus defectos que así lo
olvidarás más rápido eso hice yo con tu
padre
ella entendió
no necesariamente cuando yo le conté que
era gay sino que lo entendió cuando
comenzamos a conectarnos con esta
emoción finalmente yo había amado ese
chico quizás de la misma manera que mi
madre amo a mi papá entonces nos
encontramos en esta sensación tan humana
es cierto el desamor pero yo creo
que nos encontramos en nuestro miedo más
profundo
la soledad
cuando era niño yo veía los programas de
televisión y sobre todo los programas
cómicos recuerdo que me daba mucho miedo
ver cómo se burlaban de los hombres
afeminados no los hombres femeninos yo
entonces decidí que no quería salir del
closet
yo dije yo no quiero pasar por esta
sensación de burla y discriminación
según el último reporte de la asociación
internacional de lesbianas gay
bisexuales trans e intersex la
homosexualidad es un delito en 71 países
del mundo y hasta en 8 tiene pena de
muerte en nuestro país
en la encuesta virtual que hizo el
instituto nacional de estadística e
informática reveló que más del 65 por
ciento de nuestra comunidad había sido
víctima de violencia y discriminación
todos estos datos evidentemente resultan
desalentadores entonces probablemente es
una de las razones por las cuales
muchísima gente tiene miedo a salir del
closet
pero cuáles son las consecuencias de
este miedo en un estudio que se hizo en
el año 2003 tres psicólogos cochran
sullivan y mails señalaron que nosotros
las personas de la comunidad lgtb
tenemos mucho más riesgos de sufrir
enfermedades de salud mental en relación
a las personas heterosexuales y esto
porque esto porque vivimos en una
sensación de estrés permanente porque
tenemos que ocultarnos o vivir una doble
vida tenemos que mentir entonces con
quienes salimos cuáles son nuestras
parejas nuestros afectos nuestros
vínculos con quiénes nos sentimos
cómodos cuáles son nuestros círculos de
amigos y qué lugares frecuentamos esto
entonces nos coloca en una sensación de
completo aislamiento y por lo tanto
también en un completo y absoluto
sensación de soledad
pero todos y todas absolutamente tienen
miedo de su vida es algo muy natural es
parte del ser humano de estar vivos pero
reconozcamos que existen diferentes
tipos de miedos existen los miedos por
ejemplo hacia los insectos o estar en un
lugar cerrado no a eso que le llaman
claustrofobia pero también existen otro
tipo de miedos que le buscan hacerle
daño a otras personas
estos miedos que generan odio y rechazo
a lo desconocido o lo que a mí me genera
desconfianza como la xenofobia por
ejemplo que es el odio a las personas
que vienen de otros países o la
homofobia o transfobia que forma parte
del odio hacia nuestra comunidad pero a
diferencia de la claustrofobia que
podría ser un miedo
probablemente inofensivo la homofobia la
transfobia y la xenofobia buscan
destruir física y psíquicamente a un
otro a otra persona y a otro grupo de
personas
pero qué es la homofobia un psicólogo
yondó bid ya trató de terminarla y
utilizó tres componentes que él señaló
se encontraban interrelacionados estos
componentes interrelacionados
son el primero el estereotipo es aquello
con lo que nosotros probablemente más
nos venimos vinculando a y éste es
antinatural este de repente no a morales
inmorales este esto está mal ustedes
quieren destruir la sociedad y la
familia natural
el segundo tiene que ver con el
prejuicio
muchas veces cuando llegamos a un
espacio llegamos con una carga negativa
y esa carga negativa nos coloca a veces
en esta situación donde las personas no
quieren estar cerca de nosotros entonces
dice hagan lo que quieran pero por favor
dentro de sus cuatro paredes y el
tercero que tiene que ver con la
discriminación y esto directamente
conectado con la violencia cuando hemos
escuchado alguna vez a un periodista
diciendo si veo a dos homosexuales
besándose en la puerta del nido de mi
hija los agarró a patadas
estos tres componentes entonces
muchísimas veces se utilizan para
justificar la violencia que recibe
nuestra comunidad que muchas veces viene
como un insulto y otras lamentablemente
también con asesinatos
los últimos cuatro años han asesinado a
más de 90 personas por su orientación
sexual o por su identidad de género
hace siete años hemos podido identificar
los casos de cuatro niños que se han
quitado la vida es que se han quitado la
vida víctimas del bullying homofóbico
que han sufrido en su colegio
hace unas semanas atrás mi mamá me contó
el caso de el hijo de una vecina suya
este niño una mañana se despertó e le
dijo mamá me quiero morir que lo que
sucedía este niño era víctima de
bullying en su colegio
entonces la mamá lo sacó de ahí y el
niño perdió el año escolar la
responsabilidad entonces recayó sobre
ese niño
y es que la violencia es un hecho
traumático que afecta no solamente la
víctima sino también a todas las
personas que nos vinculamos con la
víctima o que escuchamos sobre la
violencia entonces que genera esto en
nuestra comunidad un autoconcepto
negativo de nosotros mismos una baja
autoestima la imposibilidad muchas veces
de interrelacionarnos de vincularnos de
articularnos
como no tener miedo a salir del closet
si para muchas personas ocultar nuestra
orientación sexual a nuestra identidad
de género es un acto de sobrevivencia
muchas personas tienen que mentir sobre
quiénes son para poder seguir con su
proyecto de vida pero sobre todo para
seguir con vida
sin embargo y creo que acá también viene
el esfuerzo de muchísimas personas que
vienen haciendo cosas importantísimas y
valiosas las los y las activistas en
nuestro país tienen más de 30 años
luchando y trabajando para que de
repente nosotros nuestras próximas
generaciones no tengan tanto miedo a
salir del closet
entonces que hemos venido haciendo hemos
venido articulando nos con el sector
público con funcionarios y funcionarias
con ministros con algunos congresistas
también con líderes opinión y combés
tiradores se han generado algunas
políticas públicas que las podemos
encontrar en el ministerio de la mujer
en mi ser educación en el misterio de
trabajo o en el jurado nacional de
elecciones estas políticas
buscan protegerlo de la violencia y
tratar de alguna manera de asegurar los
derechos donde todavía no hemos podido
generar algún cambio es en el congreso
de la república y es que en el congreso
de la república están todavía varios
proyectos de ley a la espera de ser
debatidos para ser aprobados como por
ejemplo unión civil o matrimonio
igualitario la ley de identidad de
género o contra los crímenes de odio
de verdad esperamos que esa espera cada
vez se acorte más
porque el momento de perderle el miedo
quienes también están dando otro paso y
desde hace unos pocos años atrás es el
sector privado el sector privado también
ha comenzado a incorporar la diversidad
del interior de las organizaciones
entonces podemos escuchar de algunas
iniciativas como pride connection que
buscan que las empresas cuenten con
políticas laborales inclusivas contra el
hostigamiento y de repente permitiendo
que las personas puedan acceder a un
trabajo digno
el sector privado ha entendido entonces
que la discriminación es un tema muy
importante y que es necesario atender
por esta razón más del 95 por ciento de
empresas del fortune five hundred
cuentan con políticas laborales
inclusivas y el 75 por ciento con
políticas exclusivas para la población
trans sin embargo necesitamos que esto
siga creciendo y que las empresas se
sigan comprometiendo también
el cuerpo tiene dos reacciones frente al
miedo
nos defendemos
o vivimos
desde hace muy poquitos años atrás tomé
la decisión de defenderme y de no huir
es por esta razón que con un grupo de
amigos y amigas creamos presente como
una posibilidad también de poder aportar
dentro del sector privado a la
generación de políticas laborales
inclusivas y también a la generación de
recursos educativos innovadores porque
algo que nos falta en nuestro país es
información y es muy necesario que las
personas comiencen a entender qué es la
diversidad sexual
nosotros tenemos muy poquito tiempo y
estamos poco a poco tratando de crecer
hace unos meses atrás en la embajada de
canadá nos de un premio por nuestro
trabajo con el sector privado y gracias
al gobierno británico
nos dieron una gran que nos permitió
empezar con un proyecto llamado empresas
presente desde ahí nosotros hemos
lanzado nuestro primer diagnóstico de
diversidad y equidad este primer
diagnóstico de diversidad y equidad lo
que busca es que identifiquemos en qué
lugar se encuentran las empresas
entonces en el perú en este momento no y
en qué momento se encuentra al menos la
convocatoria fue muy positiva
participaron alrededor de 80
organizaciones de 20 grupos distintos
incluidos tanto el sector privado como
el sector público y las ongs lo que
hemos identificado ahí es que cerca del
30 por ciento en nuestro país cuenta con
políticas laborales inclusivas se está
hablando de diversidad también en
algunos espacios el 7 por ciento cuenta
con la posibilidad de que las personas
trans que trabajan en ese espacio puedan
cambiar su nombre y que el 17 por ciento
de estas empresas ha incorporado los
mismos beneficios a las parejas
homosexuales que las parejas
heterosexuales
estos cambios ya se están dando en
nuestro país el día de hoy hay mucha
gente que está perdiendo miedo que se
está articulando que está trabajando que
se está organizando que está saliendo a
las calles o que está sentándose también
de repente en algún ministerio o en
algún congreso tratando de hacer generar
el cambio que tanto el país necesita
sin embargo las cifras nuevamente no son
tan alentadoras
según una encuesta de cpi el 80% de los
peruanos está en contra del matrimonio
igualitario el 75% en contra de la
adopción de parejas del mismo sexo y el
70% está en contra de las
manifestaciones de afecto de las parejas
del mismo sexo también en el espacio
público aún se sigue hablando de
ideología de género como esa posibilidad
de poder menospreciar aquellas teorías
que de alguna manera intentan expresar y
explicar nuestra experiencia el bullying
en los colegios es una permanente que
los docentes no saben cómo atender
aún se les sigue cerrando las puertas a
muchísimas personas trans y se les sigue
negando la existencia de las personas
cuyos no binarias de las personas
bisexuales a las personas transexuales
hasta el día de hoy a muchas mujeres
lesbianas las siguen violando para
corregir su orientación sexual
al día de hoy yo sigo con miedo y
todavía le sigo soltando la mano mi
novio por miedo a que en la calle me
griten
ya no quiero vivir con miedo
yo no tengo miedo de que me digan
en la calle pero para que esto
siga avanzando necesitamos de todos
ustedes necesitamos que ustedes también
se comprometan con nuestra lucha que
ustedes también incorporen la diversidad
en sus organizaciones en sus colectivos
en sus empresas en sus familias que
incorporen la diversidad en su vida nos
merecemos un perú donde todas las
personas nos sintamos bienvenidas sin
importar nuestra edad sin importar
nuestra procedencia origen idioma
religión orientación sexual o identidad
de género
por favor no tengan miedo
alan se presente por el futuro de
nuestro país muchas gracias
[Aplausos]